ladies and gentlemen thank you for an
amazing launch of wild ride with steve-o
we're back for episode 2 it was the last
thing that we recorded before this whole
shutdown went crazy and my guest is
clearly quite sick as we taped it I
think it's likely he's got the Rona
but hey judge for yourself he's an
incredible stand-up comedian his name is
Bert Kreischer he's a raging alcoholic
and a very dear friend I really can't
speak highly enough for how much fun we
had doing this and let's just get into
it ladies and gentlemen enjoy the wild
ride yeah okay I'm always impressed by
your techno technological know-how you
realize that's not who we saw you as
when we first met you I thought about
you the whole [ __ ] plane flight hey
guys on the podcast today's perk ricer
I thought about you on the plane the
whole [ __ ] time which plane my flight
my flight home morning yeah we got to
talk about flying when I first met ya we
were talking about loyalty programs on
Airlines and you said dude it's
executive platinum is not the highest
level of frequent flyer or what do you
call it privilege you know you said
there's a secret higher level and you
got to know about it it's not become
public it's yeah trouble for talking
about it they took it away from me at
one point people who don't understand
what we're talking about we should say
that with accumulation of frequent flyer
miles you get different levels of status
the first one being I believe gold
silver gold platinum executive platinum
and then that's where it ends on
American Airlines right but they
actually became public with with this
higher secret level which is called
concierge key you know dude I can't get
it you can't get it you get it it's
first of all it is based off of the
amount of money you spend on that
airline right it's not based on how much
you fly this drives me nuts because we
now exclusively by first
class tickets because I travel with my
service dog yeah you know and my service
dog is rather large so I was sure that
buying first-class tickets for both me
and my tour manager here Scott
that that would do the trick it's it's
it's really reserved it really is
reserved for for heads of business so
like say you're you run coca-cola you go
you know what we're moving all our
business to American Airlines and then
they're like wow okay thank you you know
what let me take care of you when you
and and then guys who fly
internationally like guys who the
concierge ski the concierge skis really
RN celebrities they give it to
celebrities but it's it's it's a weird
like I talked about it on Rogan this is
how [ __ ] elite the statuses there's a
separate entrance in LA actually you go
into someone then takes your bags and
then walks you up not just to the front
of the TSA line because they they skip
everyone that's in TSA everyone's in
first class they walk you in front of
them then they walk you in front of all
the people that are already through that
lined up to get their bags on the
conveyor belt they walk you to the front
of the conveyor belt are you saying you
don't have to go through TSA at all I'm
go through TSA but they walk you they
walk you to the very front of the
conveyor belt where you put your stuff
down they put your stuff down for you
and then send you through guy named Tony
shout out to Tony Tony gangster man Tony
came to see me do stand-up it at the at
the store one time this is my favorite
thing that's ever happened
Tony walks me to the front of the line
right it's early morning I'm all over I
feel like [ __ ] and I he walks me in
front of everyone at TSA and there's
like 20 people and this woman goes
excuse me excuse me where do you guys
think you're going and he goes on
getting him through the front of the
line she goes yeah there's a line and he
goes well he flies a lot she goes um I'm
executive platinum I file a lot and he
goes he flies so much I know his name
looks really good do I know your name is
that's how much he flies
it sucks I just lost concierge key like
two weeks ago he lost it because I
stopped flying so I gave a tour bus
right but I'll tell you what man I had a
good run this [ __ ] they did for me was
insane this the privilege that you'd get
the things that you get we're in [ __ ]
sane like I mean always you get an SUV
would always meet you when you had to go
to that that like the J gate where you'd
have to take the bus - yeah UV every
time you take the bus out there hahaha
dude SUV they pick you up they call you
when you get to the UM do the best
privilege that you got out of car Sierra
was when you're boarding you know when
against like a [ __ ] show and everyone's
around there there's a rep up at the
front of the gate we're just waiting for
you so you walk around and you don't
even let go where everyone is either
behind the counter you got behind the
counter you go hi I'm mr. Chrysler and
they're like what's Chrysler come on and
then they walk you onto the plane it was
a [ __ ] best dude and then I got in
trouble this lady called me at my house
she said Burt this is Martha from
concierge ski at American Airlines I was
like hey Martha she said listen we are
extending your service um for concierge
but I need to let you know because they
took it away
all right she goes I need to let you
know why we took it away and I said okay
she goes please do not mention us on
your comedy skits or whatever you're
doing I said what she goes she mentions
us on a very popular podcast and we do
not want anyone talking about concierge
key we don't want anyone knowing about
concierge key
this is a secret privilege that we can
ask people and so I'm like I'm
definitely not going back now after this
because they start the boarding process
with it changed now
any concierge now people like what the
[ __ ] concierge ski the best is when
you meet fellow concierge do you guys
there's a secret hand they trade stories
cuz they always go concierge ski please
board first so you get down we never see
each other it's like great white sharks
right sit down the best the best cause
here's Keith story ever I heard
ever ever ever is a long time ago guy
says um with the bar and he says sees
crosshairs on my ticket and he was
concierge ski huh yeah he goes what's
the biggest thing they ever heard of you
I go oh man they they really take care
of me he goes top this because I had a
flight out of Chicago and I was going to
a business meeting and like [ __ ]
Omaha and they were and the weather was
bad and they were canceling flights
because the other other other planes
couldn't fly him I said really he goes
yeah they got me a private jet holy why
they got me a private jet and flew me to
my [ __ ] meeting and I went home like
I never got that yeah Wow so you're on a
flight today today yeah and that's
coming back from doing shows yeah I was
in uh exactly man it is cotton to such a
blur I was in Louisville was last night
and then we drove to Nashville this
morning and from Nashville man let me
say this because I know that I was so
[ __ ] blown away when I saw you at the
store this was right after I knew you
had taped your last special which was a
secret secret time and I knew you had
just taped that so I'm thinking oh now
I'm seeing Bert at the store this is
gonna be like he's working on new [ __ ]
it's gonna be like get ready Bert's
gonna kind of suck right now and dude
you you had also just done the marathon
hey you came out with this brand-new
material about running the marathon you
had this [ __ ] bit about buying guns
dude that let me tell you something that
new this hour I just taped that hour for
Netflix that you saw I just taped that
that comes out March 17th it's called
hey big boy on Netflix that hour showed
up to me that our showed up within like
one week just randomly one week one week
my daughter got her period I bought a
gun and I had this most amazing
interaction at Starbucks on the same day
my daughter got her period and it was
like it was a tell you the exact date it
was April 13th
and I and I remember that because my
daughter joke about period parties my
daughter got a period on Friday the 13th
and April and so I literally got that
hour and I was like I remember I'm
sitting at that corner and Starbucks
going wait I just get all my material
for the next special it was like oh my
god I've already done in this new hour
I've been new hour that I'm touring now
and the birdie boy to her birdie boy
tour I love that people are calling me
pretty boy by the way people and like
when they see me on the road like birdie
boys that's what my daughter's call me
they call me boy and they call me big
boy and birdie boy my sister's coming
birdie boy my daughters call me big boy
and so I love it but this new hour I'm
in love with more than the last one
and it's just like they just show up
they just show up sometimes like
sometimes they don't and sometimes they
just show up all in like a big clump and
then you're like well [ __ ] I'm already
done night now I gotta like fine-tune it
and tighten it right but thank you is I
should have said just said thank you
[ __ ] stoked and I knew that I mean
right like he said I was like dude he
just taped especially he has all this
new [ __ ] like his new special is gonna
be even doper I'm do this that I mean I
could I could be famous say that this
will have come out like just after your
yeah yeah and what's it what's it called
is it called body shots no no the new
special is called hey big boy throughout
there's a running line where my
daughters say to me like hey big boy
right like they said that my whole life
that's how they talk to me haha remember
their whole life I'm really obsessed
with this new special because I'm very
proud of it because Bill burr said
something one time to me in passing bill
is a close friend of mine but someone I
hold very high cards he's such a genius
it doesn't he said if you're not trying
something new then you're not doing
anything at all so he said if you're not
challenging yourself on these specials
coming special special trying something
new they're not doing they'll I watched
a couple guys that I really respect I
won't say names but guys I really
respect to stand up love their spat
first special their second special
seemed like a almost like color by
numbers exact
copy of that first special same type of
joke same style of joke same topic same
premises and it seemed like they weren't
challenging themselves listen I will
always be able to write jokes and
stories about my daughter's my wife sex
drinking all that [ __ ] for me the
challenge was how do I get out of my
comfort zone and do something that is
not typically me a perfect example will
be done bit like I was like I don't talk
about firearms normally I don't talk
about anything political because I don't
like to isolate people I like everyone
laughs and so I took an approach to that
joke where I straddled offense on both
sides and have fun at both expenses and
I was like oh cool man like I'm Sam
triple he was like dude I love you have
a gun bit that does not tell anyone what
to think right but it allows them to
make a call out of it and go this guy's
definitely should know I heard you do
that bit and I was like [ __ ] I think I
might've texted you to that like I was I
was like jealous and you know I was
thinking about about some kind of a bit
for me where I go and like it buying
some kind of salt rifle you can straight
up no matter what if somebody sells me
an assault rifle that's a problem you
can even like color up a little bit by
saying some pretty freaky wild [ __ ] in
there you know like and then I thought
in conjunction with this other kind of a
long term bit his dude the bars gotten
so [ __ ] high for me what now that
I've married my stunts and my stand-up
into one
yeah you know like now I'm going out to
do all new stunts for my new hour make
an act out it's brilliant brilliant it
really is brilliant well thank you but
and it's got to be kind of tied into
where I'm at in life which is like you
know in my forty's approaching my 50s
and so I got to go to the colonoscopy
guy and I'm gonna be like the first guy
that asked the colonoscopy doctor like
so how much do you think I could fit in
my butt I was talking about trying to
shove an oscar up there but really like
if I have a goal for it to really train
and stretch you know
linked up with some dudes and gay porn
and to get tips
you know I'm determined to do this and I
figure it can't be as bad as my
degenerative disk disease which I've
found out about a couple weeks ago I
mean hell my whole body is a disaster
from me beating it up over the years and
that's probably why it's not a surprise
that I found myself waking up feeling
like a bag of dog poop but fortunately
the people from helix reached out to me
and they said we think we can help you
they had this little short quiz that you
take which determines what is the
perfect mattress for you and your
partner and I took the quiz they sent me
this mattress it showed up I honestly
couldn't believe that there was actually
a king-size mattress in that box but boy
was there we lugged it down into my room
and we opened it up kabah it was
fascinating I'll tell you right away I
knew that I felt it was more comfortable
right away I felt I got better sleep and
right away and ever since I'm woken up
feeling way better in the morning
so Thank You helix sleep and Plus don't
take this from me they got the number
one pick for mattresses in both 2019 and
2020 by both GQ magazine and Wired
magazine and why am I telling you all of
this what's in it for you well if you go
to helix sleep comm slash steve-o you
will get up to $200 off any mattress and
they will include two free pillows again
that is up to $200 off of any of their
mattresses and two free pillows if you
go to helix sleep comm slash steve-o and
you're gonna thank me I know it but
let's get back into this crazy idea I'm
giving away become a gamer become a
gamer and and if I have like a dream a
wish it would be to film the buying the
assault rifle you know whatever you
think about it I don't even want to be
involved either I would just like to see
less people get shot maybe it would be
nice you
and so to that end take one assault
rifle off the streets by melting it down
into like something that I can actually
fit up my ass getting it up your ass
[ __ ] brilliant right and I don't know
what shape is design it's gotta be the
whatever shape is gonna fit it like the
most volume in my ass it's not about
like art it's about [ __ ] logistics
how do I get an assignment you figure
the woods gonna burn there's some wood I
think involved I'm by the way I'm ready
to watch I'm brand new at podcast yeah
this I got this van for this purpose I
had van before this which was just kind
of practiced with mmm and dude I think
I've become like really pretty top notch
at being a guest on podcast amazing
guest on our podcast thank you I'm a
better guess than I am host I'm not so
much my initial idea for my podcast was
to have people come and interview me so
I was gonna be the guest all the times
and I was like in that way I could do it
with anyone and so the first one I did
was in Mexico with my bartender and I
said you wanna be the first get host on
my podcast and he was like sure the
podcast often sounded a lot like this so
who the [ __ ] are you 2010 so you started
right when Joe started Joe Joe Joe
started a Joe's been I don't know how
long Joe's named Joe Rogan's podcast
started to 2010 did it was the 10-year
anniversary Joe Joe was very III cannot
sing enough praise to Joe as a friend
and as I could just add just a cool dude
he was the first one he was like dude
you need a podcast you need a [ __ ]
podcast now even if it's just you
drinking by yourself
and talking into a microphone you need a
[ __ ] podcast I bought the equipment
set it up in my house and then I gotta
give all the credit to Tom Segura came
over to my house once
it was Easter went back and he hit
record Joey Diaz was there my dad was
there
he hit record and he goes this is your
first podcast don't edit it don't think
oh my god that's exactly where I'm at I
had so many bad [ __ ] podcasts in the
beginning where I'm gonna bring him
someone on and I'd be like what do I
talk to them about and I would just sit
there is one I did a podcast one time
with an MMA fighter and I thought he was
someone else I know him but I to do
research I listened to a podcast of
someone else
oh my god and I got in there and I was
like so you're you're like a high-level
jujitsu guy and he's like I think you're
thinking of and said the other guy's
name and as soon as he said that I went
oh my god that's exactly what I'm
thinking of I listened to this whole
podcast this other guy to prepare for
this podcast and I ended up I end up
what I do in a lot of like I did a
podcast with Jason Biggs the other day
and it was I was actually a great
interviewer like I can be a good
interview if I'm really interested in
you if I'm not interested in you you can
tell like you can definitely tell I've
had dudes and then there was a period of
time what I do is I just drink with them
I'd go if I'm gonna understand them I
was just drinking them drink with them
we'll get hammered and that'll be the
podcast but then I would say some pretty
aggressively horrific stuff drunk so I
stopped doing that and my view of what
it is has just totally you know like
been all over the place but my first
podcast I did in this fan was with Tony
Hawk as we were recording it in my head
I'm thinking oh my god this is just
[ __ ] going so great oh my god
everything I wanted to talk about we got
we got to it's like naturally segwayed
from one little thing didn't seem like I
was you know had a list of questions and
I just felt like it was so
I was even texting people after like
dude if I ever do a podcast they went
that goes as well as what we just did
with Tony Hawk I'll be so happy yeah and
then like this guy is the buddy of mine
who I'm doing this podcast with you know
he's just some guy you're like sells ads
for his friends and whatever like I'm
doing it independent and that way I love
that by the way I love that I love that
I love that that is number one my number
one thing is being independent own on
your own content do not sell it to one
of these big companies and get 50% of
the advertising find yourself an ad guy
and do your [ __ ] podcast that was
brilliant thank you he listens to the
Tony Hawk podcast I'm like what do you
think I'm just like just tell me how
awesome it was and he goes how about if
we get together and and and and like you
know go through in person I gave you
some notes and like we went sit there
and I'm like [ __ ] dude I was so excited
to have Tony Hawk there were all these
things that I wanted to say about like
skateboarding and like the and it was
just like [ __ ] man there were all these
he says right this is right here then my
podcast buddy there's an opportunity
where Tony Hawk could be telling that
like this great thing and like oh I do
that I do that aggressively I will have
I will have that exact podcast with
Justin rent some guy wrote I actually
blocked this guy cuz it bothered me so
much because he was right he goes so
you're telling me you had Justin running
your mancave and you told him stories
about you and I went yeah and he was
like dude I didn't listen to hear
stories about you I wanna hear stories
about Justin rent he is fighting for
pygmies and in Africa building wells for
them and you didn't let him talk about
it once to like oh my god like you're
cutting it down to 14 minutes here's the
other thing and I believe it's and if
you listen to this please allow this
podcast to grow and and give
constructive criticisms and be open and
constructive criticisms my biggest
criticism I ever get is I don't
listen to people I do not listen like
who the comments or the telling me a
story into my brain I'm like Burt you
gotta tell them about the time that
happened to you yeah and and then I just
Charlie up them on every [ __ ] story
and you're like like Bobby Flay dude I
did a bad one my Bobby Flay came in my
house no air conditioning in my man cave
he's in a suit it's the middle of summer
dude I bet I have a podcast with Dave
Attell were you here chickens laying
eggs and he's like we're we in [ __ ]
Guatemala like it is but I love the
broken parts of a podcast like the
broken parts make it give it a
thumbprint I was thinking about this I
was thinking about this today I was
because I know you guys are getting
together and I don't know what you can
say or what nothing I just
jackass for was announced by Paramount
Pictures yes as greenly now before I
crawl into this bag of worms let me tell
you that I have never been more excited
about a sponsor than I am about this one
it's manscaped and I am so excited
because I've been saving all of my ball
hair and bush and body hair like I've
got a bag of pubes that I've been
accumulating for almost two years now
and and this is important for two
reasons
number one I think I'm sexier and
younger looking with a nice clean body
shave plus I'm saving up the the pubes
for for something really special okay
which you don't have to worry about but
every time I harvest and I've been
documenting the process I I have cut my
balls to where they are bleeding and I'm
even like wiping blood on my face it's
awful and so like it's been driving me
nuts and then along comes manscaped with
grooming tools that I'm like I'm so
impressed I just used it okay I tried to
cut my balls wasn't happening not
possible I got this beautiful clean
shave with no discomfort whatsoever and
you can too plus if you go to manscape
calm and use the promo code steve-o you
will
get 20% off your order and free shipping
that's 20% off plus free shipping if you
use the promo code steve-o at manscaped
calm and I'm telling you your balls are
gonna thank me they're gonna thank
manscaped and so do I so thank you me
escaped and let's talk jackass I was
like why why am I so emotionally
invested in you guys like that I was
sitting there on the plane going why do
I care about Steve overbear like I
really care about BAM like like I watch
him on social media and it seems like
he's in a really good place right now I
don't know you don't have to say
anything but and like when Ryan Dunn
passed I I felt like I lost a friend
sure and I go it's because you guys
we're almost like the first podcast it
was like you guys approached media the
same way we approached podcasting
jackass let you hang out with a bunch of
guys and then you felt like you were
part of the hang like you got to you
would like the third dude in the back
seat hanging out or you were the guy on
set watching the camp you felt like your
eyes oh the camera that's what
podcasting is what it's done right it's
just someone sitting there feeling like
they're in this car so that's what I
wanna I was thinking I was like when you
are your attempt for a podcast should
just allow so I'm gonna feel like
they're sitting right here sure I think
it's when when technology gets to the
place where you can put on VR goggles
and you have a VR camera and people can
go and then actually be in this van
that's gonna be [ __ ] next level when
you can go to Rogen's when you can BR
and sit in the third seat at Rogen and
look around the room and finally look
around and feel like they're holy [ __ ]
and that is gonna be next [ __ ] level
supposed to be the biggest thing ever
and it really just wasn't but I'm gonna
say about like just the general of like
my view on podcasting is it now I just
want to be [ __ ] doing it because the
difference and what I thought the
experience was with Tony Hawk too when
we played it back was like [ __ ]
and like [ __ ] it I'm embarrassed of
the Tony Hawk podcast but I know that by
doing this I'm gonna get better at it oh
yeah dude and now I will have to say
that now I'm a much better interviewer
like I never the turn for me was with
Adam Carolla this was when I was still
doing really bad interviews and my wife
was like her laying in bed she goes I
don't what am I don't Adam Carolla bout
like I know everything about him like
what am I gonna talk to him about she
goes what do you want to know I was like
I don't know like what was it like no
she was like what really like what do
you want to know and I went how much
money he has she was like really and I
was like I want to know like when he got
fired tell you that when he got fired if
he was worried about money like he got
fired from and started doing his podcast
and she's like ask him that dude one of
the best questions I've ever asked on
the podcast I go hey when you got fired
from Radio we like nervous about money
he's like are you [ __ ] kidding me
of course I was and it was a great
conversation but it was that's what
podcasting should be is like there's no
boundaries there's no [ __ ] rules like
anyone that comes in Dane long time his
people were like dude don't talk about
his brother stealing all his money and
then we get in there and then I'm like
hey so what happened with that your
brother things tell you everything yeah
because he's a regular dude so far I
wonder if it's happening to me you just
saw my money guy leave in my house I was
wondering like who runs your money your
dad is like a business man my dad has
actually just got remarried and yeah I
think he's 76 he's like just partying
with this new new wife he has and like
and finally he's like hey you know what
dude and I'm like thank God because I've
been so codependent like dad dad but I
still have all my babysitters and my
business manager the same one for over a
decade and I shared this business
manager with Demi Lovato I think I'm in
like I think I think I'm pretty safe
from anybody doing sketchy stuff but
yeah dude and I still I want to bring it
back to the to what I was saying before
because here's the thing with with my
stand-up I've been doing stand-up now
like regularly consistently touring for
I'm in my 10th year I'm saying guys a
lot of guys picked it up and kind of
bailed
but you didn't oh my god I [ __ ] went
for it I went for it but for the first
five years even a little more it was so
difficult for me to watch footage of me
doing stand-up sometimes that would
record sometimes that would record my
set but then as I started to watch it it
would just make me so [ __ ]
uncomfortable I just couldn't do it so I
avoided watching my stand-up at all
costs and then what happened after I
recorded my first special then I put
together my second hour and and one
night on stage my head exploded I
thought [ __ ] dude all these stories that
this stand-up you know I'm telling in
this new hour like all this [ __ ]
happened on camera what if I edited the
footage into the standup like after the
fact and then it's like multimedia like
interstitial footage to like illustrate
the actual stories I'm telling and I got
so excited about it what I did was I
started recording my sets and then in
the Edit my own little had it be at the
house I started actually cutting the
footage into it and it worked great but
what that did was it forced me it
physically [ __ ] forced me to watch me
doing stand-up and it was so
uncomfortable but the things that made
me the most uncomfortable I would flag
them like [ __ ] I hate it when I do that
[ __ ] I hate it when I do that and I
would just simply I would address things
yeah I would say dude a lot I say dude a
lot I go dude like I'll start it
struggle to dude like and I'd and I was
like I would say [ __ ] a lot I say [ __ ]
so much on stage but when you watch it
you're like god damn it
like stop saying [ __ ] dude right
that's all I do you gotta watch it dude
you have to watch it like once I started
doing that like the growth in my
stand-up was like compared to the five
years before it was exponential I mean
it just got so much more just so much
more comfortable and whatever so I just
think I want to apply that to podcasts
dude I listened to my first year I
listen to all my
castes and I would be like goddamn it
what are you doing
you're stepping all over this guy this
guy's got a great story and then you're
just jumping in and going let me tell
you my story and it's you gotta listen
to him in and also I think it helps
being a fan of podcasts like when you're
a fan you can listen to other podcasts
and go oh I would have done that like
like I'll tell you the best podcasts out
there at Rogan and Marin Rogan Marin
just are consistently [ __ ] great
interviews I mean I steal from both of
them on my podcast consistently like
just like well the guests are so
entertaining yeah nobody but trust me
when I say you can [ __ ] that up yeah
put-put
Rhonda Patrick on my podcast I could
make that a boring interview
she's the nutritionist the girl who's
all about like sauna lifestyle a job a
sauna in my house because of her they
said dress on I mean I've been looking
it up on Amazon it's like 1800 bucks
she's pretty for sure
I took the 23andme and sent my info into
her website and then she calculates all
your [ __ ] and tells you what you should
eat based off your DNA okay yeah and
should I go you you probably don't like
selling really well Louis you're a fan
of Tito's and soda no but they're like
basement burgers these are wings yeah
but they're like based off where you
live like somebody from like Norway's
not going to benefit off of eating
pineapple or bananas because it's just
not from the region they're from she's
like oh you like reindeer she's like
yeah you probably do like you more than
likely have a middle toe longer than the
other toes you're in the end they'll go
through like each quirk that you would
have based off of like what you send in
there and they're pretty accurate like
blood work analysis of like what like
food allergies I might or might not have
I don't trust [ __ ] 23andme for that
[ __ ] there's no better way my sent in
for a food sensitivity test where you
prick your finger and send it in to tell
you what you are
meanwhile I shouldn't be talking [ __ ]
about 23
because it was one of the potential
advertisers that my buddy brought up
this morning at breakfast hey they're
great over twenty three Emmys a public
overcast joke I've ever heard uh kinda
wish I remember this guy's name he's out
of he I think he owns the stand in New
York he's a really smart dude he was
like a business guy that got into
stand-up he goes I got my 23andme
results back
I am 98% sit as Sephardic Jew Jewish and
2% sub-saharan Africa you know that
wasn't a date I found out I'm four
percent Jewish why don't why don't you
care about that because I'm so [ __ ]
fascinating to me like where you're from
I just don't care it doesn't change my
[ __ ] life or what I'm gonna like you
know do you care about knowing where you
from yeah
do you know where you know so funny uh
one time I was talking to this Native
American guy on stage and I said so
what's your I think background he goes
Native American I said what kind he is
Island I like think Cherokee or
something and I went oh and you don't
know and he was like no I was like
what'd you do you should know that he
was what are you I said I reset Bank and
he goes you're telling me I should be
more interesting to myself because I'm
Native American he goes you're not
interested in yourself and I was like
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] I am
either I'm like why would I well I
assumed if I was Native American I'd be
more fascinated with my lineage
something that when the politically
correct term for black people is
african-american I got to imagine that
that would drive anybody nuts to be like
like why are you assuming that I came
from Africa like I Bank [ __ ] call do
not that is lesson number one I learned
and stand up in learn at Miami
do not call a black person
african-american they [ __ ] get livid
black don't even go anywhere near no
because people are Jamaican people are
maybe people are from Dominican they're
African Americans so about calling
someone African American and Miami such
a melting pot i call someone
african-american you're assuming right I
mean the whole purpose of America was to
not be from America right based on
immigrants they called a melting pot
yeah it's uh more of a TV dinner really
[Laughter]
a high school in England you know
when I got to the University of Miami at
18 years old I forgot I had I had not I
had not [ __ ] lived in America from
the age of nine so when I got to America
I was like what everybody wants to fight
like that's all physical jocks like
trying to be intimidating that wasn't
part of my lifestyle that wasn't
something I was used to and the the
aggressive racism I was like [ __ ]
everybody's so racist what the [ __ ] you
know the racist in England too with a
bananas on the field when the black guys
play soccer
really I thought on real time not real
time real sports where do they say about
that they're like oh come on we're just
it's contest like it's been going on for
thousands of years
yeah well that's weird um I forgot you
went to University of Miami yeah
oh my god the best joke at Florida State
what they like God when they're cheering
in the stadium for their football team
the Seminoles because it's the Florida
State Seminoles which are a Native
American tribe like they've got this
thing the Tomahawk Chop that they do and
it's the same exact Tomahawk Chop that
the Atlanta Braves fans do at the
baseball stadium in Atlanta the question
is what is the difference between the
Atlanta Braves Tomahawk Chop and the
Florida State Seminoles Tomahawk Chop I
don't know at Florida State you get
three credits for doing it do a show and
I just cancel it no no I don't know I
just so I have no interest in so what
you taking a bus there sorry to cut you
up yeah yeah no I fly in to City then
I'm the bus needs to be at the airport
we'll do like four cities and then I fly
home it's Sunday four days yes well this
week we're doing Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday okay this week
we're in Boston we're doing three shows
that may need you a different tour bus
every time Oriole meets you same tour
bus dude this is the greatest thing I've
ever done in my life on the same tour
bus I have everything I want on the tour
bus right I get the first day it comes
to LA and it we just lose the camera the
so the first day the bus comes out to LA
and I pulled up to my house and I loaded
up all my [ __ ] put some weights in there
put like couple pre-rolled joints I get
everything everything everything like
I'm not a big weed guy but I can take if
I take a hit then I stop drinking and so
for me I'll take like a hit and then
pass out um I put I get all my food
get my spice certain like paintings I
like to have on the bus I am I turn it
into my home I let it tours with me for
you know four months and it stays out in
the road so when I fly I just have
sweatpants backpack headsets phone
wallet and that's it so I don't have to
end up to bring anything on the road
it's so great all my blood pressure
medicine I got blood pressure medicine
on the bus I got it at home it's like
the greatest thing I've ever done in my
entire life I love it more than anything
you wake up one of my favorite things in
the world one of the things that I loved
about jackass was in it it felt like I
felt like you guys were at camp together
like you guys felt like you guys were
like vacationing together and the
greatest feeling in the world is when
you're with a bunch of guys and I just
say guys I mean be your friends and you
guys wake up in the morning and you're
hungover and you're like you're like hey
last night it was crazy huh
I'm gonna check they got pulled out of
the bar by her back of her neck and
you're like oh [ __ ] you saw that that
congrat that congregating in the morning
of like we get that on the tour bus
every [ __ ] morning every [ __ ]
night bring as many as I can
I have I try to have three openers shane
torres vedras Trejo and dave williams
biggest fear in the world well I checked
my heart my heart rate when I get up
there and the first the first fight
every time which I try to keep it like
30 minutes so ten each or they do 15
each of its two of them or yeah I don't
like I'm going much longer because I do
an hour and a half but um but yeah and
so and then we have my tour bus driver I
have a tour manager and the content
provider so content content producer and
so Instagram like promo videos so I'm
Alli sell a lot of tickets through
Instagram and so if I can just have a
guy with me with a camera to catch stuff
and then I can I'm just flipping out
like I told Dilber I could kick a
33-yard field goal so we're at Pat Mack
at these compound
for the Colts and he we [ __ ] around
and I put it up do it on Instagram threw
on some dates for New York at the end of
it BAM
so we do a three-minute clip which goes
to Facebook YouTube and then we do a
one-minute clip for Instagram don't call
that guy Pat McAfee on that I mean he's
talked about stuff that you know I'm out
just saying that I hadn't [ __ ] done
my jackass for deal yet
and he was talking head heard the
announcement from Paramount it's just
like talking about Jack has four and at
a certain point it became like it felt
like didn't make sense to be pretending
that like I had my deal done so I just
like blurted it out yeah I don't know my
deal done yet you know and he was like
huh and it was just like turned into
like you know [ __ ] can of worms kind
of I can't imagine how [ __ ] I can't
imagine how sticky and complicated that
would be no matter how you're
approaching it you know I see when you
know the the the the thing you're going
to make is going to make lots and lots
of money it's got to be it's got to be
very difficult I can only imagine do we
lose another camel you know I was
thinking about that I was like I
wouldn't even want to go into it I
wouldn't want to ask about it that's why
it bothers me like I have a podcast with
Bill burr of a podcast with segura cave
two guys one cave is being scurrilous me
and Tom are have are me and Bill have
bill Bert the bill bird podcast we got
smoked cigars we smoked cigars well how
about I have a cocktail bill doesn't
drink anymore but yeah what's it's and
and even doing business with your
friends in that capacity is I find it
uncomfortable
sure like like I just said to my
business manager I was like hey are we
getting paid and he was like yeah I was
like cool never mind we getting paid
what like like with the Tom thing I was
like I really like Tom and I've been
doing it for a while he was like yeah
he's like I deal with Tom and I was like
okay cool yeah like I don't even bring
it up I do
I don't even bring it up like it just
makes me so uncomfortable we feel like
you're stepping on his toes I'm not that
guy okay how much money am I making you
know like I'm not that guy at all I
would do it for free I would do the
podcast for free I love a man love Tom
like the brother but I giggle with that
guy so hard and those podcasts sells so
many tickets for me on the road I would
do him for free but if we're all making
money I would want to get paid as well
but I that just makes me uncomfortable
to the core to talk about money I was I
was just kind of frustrated because I in
in my view I was like men like [ __ ]
I've been so active for over the last
ten years you know like I just felt you
know that my story all along was you
know if we make another movie great if
we don't make another movie like I'm
doing I'm behaving exactly the same
anyway and so I just felt frustrated
that paramount like kind of just didn't
seem to want to recognize that I've like
stayed really active and kind of kept
the flames alive you know and that that
like I have a story where people are
rooting for me let me tell you with that
with I don't know the people paramount I
apologize I don't know anyone at
Paramount I don't know anyone at Fox I
don't know anyone at CBS but I will tell
you there they live in a bubble and
their bubble is starting to fall apart
around them and they don't realize it
and they don't realize that guys like me
and you are making millions of dollars
on our own and we're and we're not using
the system we have no attachment to the
system right um and that the system
can't find us that's why they're trying
to take ro
you know see what CNN did they kind of
came out and said I think they came out
and said some [ __ ] about him and the
reason is he's the number one media
outlet in the world right now and and
they can't control him he decides that
he wants to vote for [ __ ] out we gotta
take this guy down
I mean I don't know that's what's
happening but that is what's happening
in my book is you go to a meeting and
I'll tell you right now I go to a
meeting at a place I won't say names but
big networks and they come they go so we
want to do a pilot and I go now and
they're like wait but I was like I'll
just do it on my own I'm like what do
you mean I was like I just make it my
own and put on youtube and I'll sell
tickets I don't need you like have a
larger platform as any much larger
platform they have no more power that's
the problem
[ __ ] many people have tried to buy
something's burning my cooking show and
I'm just like no I like the way I do it
I like the way I do it and I don't want
to sell it to anyone if you want to do
it the way I do it then you can do that
by the way my production budget is
$2,000 so how the [ __ ] are you gonna
compete with that
I can foot that bill on my own make the
product I want put it out for the fans
the way I want to I'm not gonna go to
you dude I just did a show I just did a
show with Netflix like a series and um
and I was so blown away like because as
you see this right here next time you're
gonna do radio you'll look around and
you'll be like god dammit you like throw
wasting a lot of money right wait I did
that Netflix oh well the first thing I
was saying is like oh no we're wasting
so much money and my head writer Mike
Gibbon said hey this isn't your money
you don't get to take it home don't
worry about any of that like just make
the product they want to make and you're
like oh yeah
because I got into I got into such a
mindset of like I can make this quicker
faster and cheaper that it was it was
hindering me and and but you realize
like when the budget for Jackass has got
to be like [ __ ] do you remember but
do you remember you guys used to make
jackass for like 15 grand an episode
that's I mean it's so [ __ ] insane is
that you could make that product or
your own but but but why not why not
everyone make millions and get the [ __ ]
out you know but it's like that's where
I get that's where I that's my Hill to
die on his like I always want to make
things cheaper and on my own I just want
to it's interesting too that when you
say you're in the radio station and
they're wasting all this money but at
the same time according to our buddy
Mike COUNTA in Florida his the biggest
radio DJ in the Tampa Bay area
he says the terrestrial radio is alive
and oh it is it is for him it is for
Elliott in the morning it is for Preston
and Steve it's for Todd and Tyler for
Bob and Tom it is alive in some places
but he will admit it is dying a very
[ __ ] hospice e death all over the
[ __ ] country all it's doing is it's
getting rid of the the dead weight and
it's allowing guys like him to really
establish their platform like his you
you'll know the market see where you can
go in you do radio and sell tickets
people still listen they definitely
still listen man there's a lot of
markets where they don't [ __ ] listen
at all go and try to do a [ __ ] show
in San Francisco no one's I bet I've
never met them but I'm sure they're
dudes are you still doing radio in the
morning for for press or no gasps I'm
out yeah let's talk about touring do you
have a Facebook guy this is one of the
best things I've done I don't I don't
have to promote my [ __ ] tour dates on
Instagram anymore because I've got this
this guy that we hired to do Facebook
campaigns which are specifically
geo-targeted so that they only show up
in the area where that show is you put
some money behind it to reach more
people in [ __ ] it's like you know when
we turn on these campaigns we get to
ticket counts and it's like [ __ ] I used
to do that I used to do that when I was
doing clubs I did that now it's like I
what I did what I've done now is I yeah
I mean I can talk about it
but I signed a different type of deal I
signed a deal with a promoter and so
yeah like one of those and uh and so I
have a marketing budget and I just put
money I make my own content and then
geo-targeting doesn't work as well for
me what I do is I do one big video like
the dancing video or roller skating
video or I'll do one video and that'll
sell it the today tickets and then
within exclusive theaters and I'm pretty
much exclusively in comedy clubs and the
gap between those two situations is so
frustratingly big it's you know it's
like it is I went I was in Louisville
last night and I had said my first thing
I said I said where were you
[ __ ] for 15 [ __ ] years I
couldn't sell a ticket in Louisville
once I couldn't sell one [ __ ] ticket
and Louisville my whole career my whole
[ __ ] career not one [ __ ] ticket as
a matter of fact I had the dregs of
society at my shows that I would have to
kick out of that [ __ ] Club and then
last night 2,800 people on a Sunday
night yeah and you're like lot of it's a
lot of it is there when I was younger
that someone said I believe in the
longtail theory I said what's that and
they're like just the more [ __ ] you have
the more [ __ ] you'll knock over like a
dog with a longer tail knocked over more
stuff then a guy with just like one
thing like a little sitcom it's like a
little nub tail but if you got a sitcom
a radio show a movie and and a special
then all of a sudden you're not going I
think it is my podcasts have three
podcasts my cooking show I think it's
the fact that I heavily mark it like I'm
cognizant of set of mentioning where
I'll be when I'll be there and and the
Netflix special the Netflix special is a
[ __ ] huge game changer but there are
people touring that don't have a Netflix
special Andrew Schultz huge tour no
Netflix special deal bomb huge
or no Netflix special um you know pot
brought Brendan Brendan Schaub bryan
callen huge tour no nefler special right
so a lot of it is I mean podcasting is
you know when you're getting into half a
million ears a week you know all you
really need to sell is 70,000 tickets
total successful theater tour that's it
right so if you can get into 70,000 ears
and get those people to come see you get
into that second show you second show so
yes I mean you add a second show that's
the [ __ ] whoo so let's hypothetically
say you do the Wilbur Wright first time
you're gonna go in your part gonna do
$20 tickets I'm guessing you walk out
maybe 10 grand I'm guessing that's what
you get on that first show when you add
a second show your walk out is now goes
from that $10,000 show you get the
lion's share
so you'll maybe go to 50,000 for two
shows so you get 40,000 for the next
show I'm I'm sure my math is all for it
by the way but but it's that's the leap
is like well this this jackass movie is
going to yeah exponentially help
especially and by the way I know you're
not gonna try to tell some type of story
or narrative about where you are from
when they found you to where you are
today is such a different human [ __ ]
being it is ridiculous and what you're
doing on the road is acknowledged by
legit professionals in this business
like myself Segura Rogan everyone agrees
you're not just here to buy a [ __ ]
lake house you're here because you love
comedy like that's it's it's your thing
you do stand-up you do spots in round
city you go out you on you're on tour
you're in the clubs like the fact that
like let it's not a passing phase and so
when I think this jackass movie comes
out I think it's gonna be really big for
your touring like really big I've been
just carrying on so grateful to finally
be doing this [ __ ] podcast
I'm just letting myself not be a bag
[ __ ] good at it and I think that
already like this is by the way this is
by the way you keep saying you're not
good at it this is a great there's a
great podcast right here unless you've
ever done you know man it's do you buy
into people in life I do at least Ben
Affleck I bought I bought into that dude
time ago I was like he's my guy like I'm
him and Matt Damon they're my guys I
like him
I'm an always like what they do I'm
always like them for whatever [ __ ]
reason that goo boo honey movie got me
and I was like all right they're my guys
they're my new Harrison Ford's and and
[ __ ] unlike that with Mark Wahlberg
yeah I love Mark Wahlberg I love like
Dirk the shooter Dirk Diggler they're
[ __ ] john c reilly uh-huh fall lovable
ferrell kristen wiig will you go
anything you do I'm in on you I remember
where I was when I first saw jackass
obviously you know I have a connection
with Johnny Knoxville cuz we did some I
met him before jackass but when you
[ __ ] spit up that goddamn goldfish I
would remember I remember where I was
and I was like I [ __ ] love this guy
man and there's there are there is a
thing about your personality that
everyone has a stibo in their life like
who you were when you're not younger
know who you are today
you're a very different man you're you
have taken such I hope you take this a
compliment you've taken such a [ __ ] show
of a dude to such a [ __ ] high place
we're like it's in so impressive man
like honestly you're one of the more
impressive guys when I look at who you
are
where you are today in your work ethic
and like how passionate you are about
[ __ ] from the guy that I met that spin
up the goldfish you know and just seeing
you that is like from the guy that was a
[ __ ] taking ketamine like crazy and
[ __ ] destroying his apartment the
fact that you're here is [ __ ]
overwhelming I had a I had a I had a kid
one time tell me this it's a really
interesting statement for a drunk dude
with no shirt and wentz bombed to make
it was New Year's Eve and I was doing my
meet and greet I'm shirtless and this
guy's [ __ ] wasted and he's like he's
a gay man can I get like two minutes
your time and I'm you know immediately a
meet and greet you're like oh god
yeah and the end the bouncers like hey
moving on I don't know give me I give me
a second and I go what's up buddy he
goes alright I'm a fan do you know what
that means I said no because it means
when you succeed I succeed I said I
don't follow when he goes hear me out
hear me out
I don't got much going on in my life man
but I picked you I picked you through
all the podcasts you're the guy that
made me laugh the hardest and you're my
guy I buy your merch I come to new shows
and when you succeed I feel like I
succeeded because I made the right
decision you'll show you a fan of and I
went like I'm a fan of I'm a fan of uh
of wilcos like my favorite band and he
goes he was when they when good things
happen but you get excited for him I go
yeah I do and he was that's what a fan
is and then he said that and I started
going through of all the people I'm fans
of and I was like yeah that's [ __ ] so
crazy like I like it like yeah like when
you see when you pick your people we and
they may do something big you're like
[ __ ] yeah that's my guy and and and and
what is sad is there are people that are
too cool to be fans and I get that I
won't use you because you're here
Bam Margera right Bam Margera Ryan Dunn
those guy I am I was legit a fan of Ryan
Dunn's
like legit mr. [ __ ] that guy for
whatever [ __ ] reason he embodied all
of a [ __ ] I liked like all of it there
was a [ __ ] time when they were up on
a scissor thing on Viva La Bam and they
were stuck up there for like [ __ ]
four hours and then someone came out and
said you guys had the keys up there and
they didn't realize they put up there
for four hours and I was crying laughs
and that's what
I fell in love with those dudes yeah so
when I watch BAM go through his tough
times I get bummed out for I do I get
bummed out for him and I'm like come on
buddy we got we got this knot you got
that we got this and then when I see him
like hanging out with his kid and being
in a good place skateboarding with his
kid or hitting a ramp and you go oh he
must be in good shape because he's
landing tricks I get excited for his his
successes make me happy dude once you
subscribe to that and you get that
everything [ __ ] makes sense
everything [ __ ] love it and I'll take
a step further as it relates to BAM like
I will you're friends with him so like
I'm really close to them at the BAM
situation and my experience was I didn't
even meet him and so we were filming the
second season of Jackass and and before
like before we were filming the second
season of Jackass like I got my hands on
his CKY tape this is after the first
season had already aired and I got my
hands on his CK y2k video which is one
something he'd distributed all by
himself
it was so [ __ ] mind-blowing to me
because I was trying to get in people's
videos he was like [ __ ] that he produced
it edited it distributed it all by
himself
and it was incredible and I was so
[ __ ] jealous of this kid dude my god
my buddy was making a porno and as I'm
watching this at my buddy's house he's
banging this chick on camera I'm just
like pounding on the door dude we gotta
go like like I was certain I was like we
gotta I gotta do something I'm so
jealous BAM you know I just about the
6-foot balcony into a pool and and we
were on liquid acid that day and I went
and threw myself off a bridge while
walking on stilts it was just my
response to being jealous of BAM yeah to
take that and go and to revert it and go
I'm gonna take this energy right now
just work harder yeah I'm jealous and
thank you for motivating me to get that
[ __ ] stilts off bridge [ __ ] you know
in a bigger sense it's like he was
younger than me he was more successful
than me he was a better skateboarder
than me way richer more creative
better-looking
you know lying across the boards BAM
when tile
music the [ __ ] kid had every sewer
flush I remember we would just be like
the [ __ ] he's got a [ __ ] Lamborghini
what like we were recording the [ __ ]
second season of Jackass he had just
been to the Audi dealership wasn't sure
which one he liked best so he bought two
at the same time and I was I was a fan
of him and then now like to see him go
through the times the tough times then
you know whenever he's on TMZ it's been
bad and like I tell him that you know
I've told him straight up to his face
like dude
like I was always so jealous of you and
I just I deeply deeply want to be
jealous of you again you know a really
beautiful statement yeah that's yeah
it's funny man it's funny it's funny too
because you're willing to allow it when
you're a fan of someone you're willing
to allow them to [ __ ] up because you
want to see this fade how about the
people that you're fans of and then you
follow them on social media and ready
for this so there's another theory I
have and this applies the cancel culture
it's a branding issue okay it's a
branding issue if you put yourself out
as someone and I buy into that and then
I find out you're not the person you
sold me as I'm out I'm [ __ ] out
forever
I can't deal with that I think that's a
part of the reason I have a hard time
quitting drinking is because everyone
knows that I like to have a drink my
party and I feel like the second I and I
think a lot of my fans or people that
you know who love weight have a beard
have a hotter wife than they deserve
they like to party they get their lives
you know they can get [ __ ] done but they
could do better but like I think that's
you know not not to speak and at school
about anything but that was what
happened with Aziz when because he came
out is this like I don't
I know I'm not trying to talk [ __ ] about
disease I know that he went through a
lot with that [ __ ] I'm not trying to add
on but like let's do Louie Louie's a
better example okay see Louie Louie's
told himself as this dirtbag I'm a dirt
bag on piece of [ __ ] that's who I am
everyone believed that but they didn't
really believe it they were like oh he's
a great guy he's great guy and then he's
like not a jerk off in front of a couple
checks everyone's like what the [ __ ] and
it's there in their their branding comes
out different in their head you know
Aziz was this woke Bay like I'm a
feminist I'm a FEMINIST and then it
turns out you know he likes get [ __ ]
funky with chicks and putted their
fingers in their mouth and their [ __ ]
well that did the branding dis
disassociated his fans that's when you
lose fans is when your branding comes
off wrong but you can't lose fans by
being a [ __ ] up dude but when you were
at your lowest your fans were like come
on steve-o you can't go out like this
right now
you can't go out like this man I got
what he's when he goes I remember this
post so vividly I think I texted you
when BAM was like man I'm them so I just
got robbed what are you gonna do you
know I've sent my I'm gonna have a beer
and I've got my throne I was like you
don't need to tell me the story just
have the beer man we get it beer that
beer was gonna come whether or not your
mom he already had the beer then he
walked out to make the statement then he
said yeah whatever
with Ben Affleck but Ben Affleck laughs
like when you know when when you see him
struggle he came out of a Hollywood
party and he's wasted I go I got your
brother I got you don't worry your next
movie I'm gonna watch it like I'm still
here for you you're my guy tumble all
you need to do like lose the [ __ ]
dead weight that wasn't there for the
[ __ ] ride right that's all I'm stuck
on what you just said before about
that's why I don't want to stop drinking
because like I'm hearing you say that
you identify that as like your identity
I think I think a lot of people it's
like if you found out I mean look at all
this James head
James Hetfield was a hundred percent
beer in his hand every concert the whole
time cheers to the crowd like where was
anybody [ __ ] mad at him for stopping
drinking yeah no but I think he was what
is he like fifty something when he
stopped eighteen years right he just
went back to rehab but dude [ __ ] it
was they made this some kind of monster
movie and that was like I want to say
2005 or something so 15 years ago he
wasn't and and I remember too that I
just got my little nine-month chip you
know at the dorm
whenever either I got sober in 2008 all
right and and I went to Metallica
concert and they brought me backstage to
meet James Hetfield he was in his own
like little space dude was just glowing
man you could see sobriety like all over
me he made it look so good it glows one
you man
Thanks it glows on you by the way I look
like garbage right now because I drank
all morning but just a quick story I
told him I asked him how long have you
been sober and he said seven years at
that point this was in December of 2008
so he get sober and she doesn't won and
I said dude just got my nine-month chip
and I pulled it out it's this little
plastic like round like poker chip kind
of thing and you get plastic ones and
then then when it's a year it's a metal
medallion and I'm like my nine-month
chip I said no more plastic for me
straight
heavy metal from here on out like which
is my way of saying that I was going to
like be diligent and do the work of a
sobriety but dude I just like don't feel
like you owe it to your [ __ ] fans to
keep drinking like it'll be man I'm I
can feel that around the corner I just
feel I feel like I feel like I'm I look
at myself and I go like about betraying
brands like I buy it I buy it because
it's like it's one thing if if you're
[ __ ] not genuine it's one thing if
you're if you [ __ ] lie to people and
yeah
but if I try stop drinking it and then
I'm cool with that I think my think
people would still come see me what
about worried about that horse of course
for me it's like it's like I I feel like
I'm still so young and in in everything
even though I'm old but like like I go
out to bars with my fans after the
show's I'm by the model bar how many
yeah I do I do a raffle for the
meet-and-greet so everyone can buy you
might as many tickets as you want and
and we pull 20 names they can bring as
many people as they want we do that meet
and greet and then I name a bar in the
city and I go to that bar if you weren't
drunk it'd be like I get high more I
smoke a little weed and then it just
it's like there's a like this and so um
maybe I maybe take we talked about last
night maybe take about 500 pictures
right there probably is throughout a
night and what by the way I don't mind
out what really bothers me is the person
who gets four or five pictures with me
like one more man I'm like we already
got it like October
October's it's it's you know it's a it's
a game it's like a fun everyone knows
that the rules to it no drugs no alcohol
fitness I love Socktober every time I
get done so October I go I might be done
forever how how many how long have you
felt like quitting drinking is just
around the corner because I remember
when you came over to watch the special
at Steve's yeah you were saying like you
know I think it was like sober October
October and you were like you know I
think this might be it everything every
summer October I go this is it and then
and then I I get drunk that first time
and I [ __ ] hate it
I hate that wake up next morning I go
why am I doing this to myself and then
and then I don't know it just creeps
back into your life and you have a
bottle of wine with your wife and then
you know someone brings out we'd like I
might as well take a hit and you know
this lasts over October I got ma lead
right before so October started I just
started talking about it on stage okay I
don't know what really brings it up okay
talked about a Ron Rogen and everyone
just kind of was like they knew I wasn't
it wasn't like it wasn't super funny to
me when it happened like it wasn't like
you'd expect
you know comedian to be like dude that
was [ __ ] crazy nobody nobody in the
[ __ ] world would ever think that was
bad for those people listening or don't
know
Berndt had a comedian Airy Shaffir over
in his house they were recording a
podcast Bert's kids were [ __ ] home he
had to go to the airport shortly like
shortly after the podcast that very same
day and they were like hey let's you
know let's have a couple drinks together
mellow and so Airy Shaffir [ __ ] doses
birds drink with [ __ ] Molly's and all
of a sudden Birds [ __ ] like having an
intense hardcore drug experience in
front of his [ __ ] kids having to go
to the airport to [ __ ] get on an
airplane [ __ ] rolling on [ __ ]
Molly nobody thinks that's [ __ ] cool
the guy on the flight next to me got the
best back massage ever no I just started
talking about it because uh Rogan was
like hey man you can't you sure you can
talk about that on stage I just was like
I didn't know how to approach [ __ ] [ __ ]
with Ari and people just start disliking
I was thinking about that we were
driving over to do this with you and I
was thinking about that like where do I
stand on all that you know like weird
like I I don't want to like pile on
you're Hawk cancel cultural egglets they
like harm this guy and harm his
reputation I'm not I'm not out to do
that I'm not the [ __ ] police but what
were the one thing out of all that like
I'm not gonna say oh that it wasn't a
joke it wasn't funny like I mean that's
just subjective what's not subjective
for me and it's about that being on
brand thing is I'm saying I was hacked
oh yeah but no but that was actually a
joke ah that was the joke was it was
such a horrible statement that he wrote
oh hey guys I was hacked and then you
know I I'm definitely not gonna sit here
and defend re but I have in the past um
I think what [ __ ] him up was the video
if he had just left the tweet the video
what video is weird it's like remember
one right yeah you heard ray rice hit
his wife and you're like like oh he's
and they've dealt with it it's gonna be
fine he'll be back next week then they
showed you saw the video very much that
he was right there like oh that's a
little different yeah [ __ ] he
[ __ ] hit me hit her hey I've never
been hit that hard in my life and so I
think our video was was videos so much
worse than that in that case and that in
oddly enough but um it's you know
there's I don't think there's any right
way to deal with that what happened to
him I don't he was going to he it's such
a [ __ ] show in in all respects of like
III don't know what that kind of
scrutiny is like to have that many
people tweeting death threats and
tossing me I don't know what what
protocol is no one knows what protocol
that is so you're just making decisions
flying by the seat of your pants hoping
they're right and even the decisions
that I offered him in that time where I
was like this is what I think you should
do and in retrospect were wrong and and
and like I say well in me maybe he
thinks so and so I I know Tom and I
talked about it and we you know said
what we said on our podcast and he was
very upset by that
I don't know man I really like you know
I think that you were pretty pretty
objective pretty fair yeah I think Tom I
thought so too but you know also in that
time when he's upset he's also going
through all this fear of his life and
and being assaulted and so I'm sure he
wasn't thinking clearly you know during
that time either but uh but yeah and and
and and then I didn't want to talk about
the Molly stuff because it's right on
the tails of this Kobe thing and it's
just like I fella girls piling on and
Jose I mean you can demolish that on
stage was that it was I think sober I
was right before sober October than one
that he dosed you and it's you and it's
Segura and it's area should fear it's
broken all in the same [ __ ] room and
like the story comes out I felt like I
mean I was like pissed off for you in a
way that just everyone was kind of like
maybe because he was in the room maybe I
think it was I mean Joe and I talked
after that and he was like hey man I
don't think I ma'am not I don't like
speaking for Joe and I don't like
sharing private conversations but I
think I'm okay to say this he was like I
don't think the weight of that hit me
when you told me on the podcast I don't
think I I don't think I understood what
how [ __ ] up that was I wanted to wait
to hit I know but I think what happened
was I had told segura on the phone and
Segura said I was [ __ ] up and the
weight didn't hit him and tell that
podcast when he was on that podcast he
was like yeah man you told me on the
phone and I didn't really understand it
and he goes and I think that's what Joe
was going through is he heard it but he
didn't understand it and then two days
later is like wait that was really
[ __ ] up and so it was a really weird
situation in this weird situation when
you live your life out on podcasts out
in the open like that
we're like you're like you roll the dice
am I gonna become a meme you know like
like what the [ __ ] yeah whose it was
dude the thing that sucked about it is a
month or for all of sober October my
serotonin levels were off and so I was
like going to hardcore depression and
anxiety also October so I didn't even
get to enjoy sobriety the way I had in
the past I never felt I felt at unease
because you're rolling so hard okay no
because you know I think when you do
Molly
think I don't know but I'm assuming it
borrows good energy and floods your head
with that and then the next couple weeks
you gonna rebuild that good energy like
it takes from tomorrow and so I had
anxiety attacks throughout the entire
month
are you are you and re 100% our is it
like 92 no we're fine I don't know I
would I mean look I told him I said it
definitely changes a lot of things you
never allowed my house again my wife
hates him to death my wife my kids my
kids [ __ ] hate him like yeah what
sucks sucks is I loved him I lent him
connected on so many things they're both
weirdo brains and I loved him and then
she saw me texting him what was at my
sister's house she saw me texting him he
owes Oh why would you text him and I
went oh it's complicated because it's
not complicated she goes dad he almost
killed my dad and I went huh she goes
wait how would you feel if I was texting
someone who drugged me no oh my god I
would not like it
she went grab my phone and I went [ __ ]
[ __ ] everything up man like my you're
never gonna be allowed in my house again
that's what made me so upset as I go and
he just it he you know I mean we've
talked on the phone we've talked a
couple times I haven't really seen him
um you know in the COBE stuff went down
I texted him a couple times I called him
that Monday you know and talked to him a
little bit but uh but you know it's it's
complicated but you know I think that if
anything I'm very capable of forgiving
people maybe too capable good he was
scheduled to tape a new Netflix special
right did that just go away yeah well it
was it was he was paying for it himself
I don't know if Netflix had bought it
yet but he was paying for it for himself
and not to speak to out of school once
again but I think it was just a
liability issue of the people working on
there were a little nervous there were
death threats but but it sounded like it
sounded like the tickets were sold
people were still got he ended up doing
the shows the
those were awesome you know I don't
think I don't think cancel culture I
think it only applies when you let it
apply I guess cuz I don't think
anything's really changing for him he
didn't have any tour dates he was done
his tour you know he's doing shows in
New York no one's approaching him no one
seems to be right yeah I don't think
he's gonna be hosting America's Got
Talent and he's but he seems to be doing
fine and then kind of oblivious to the
you know he was stayed offline so he was
really oblivious to the backlash like he
just stayed offline and I was like I was
like I was like wow I checked it out a
couple times
that's like not a guy I know
gone through was really upset
Bryan Callen was really upset and
Michael Rapaport beyond them was
measured Cal was measured on the podcast
it was it was it was a super tricky
situation to be put in as his friend
no no but and I think that was the
wisest thing anyone is cuz it's really
hard in that moment to say hey this guy
is not the villain cuz he did do
something that everyone sees as hateful
he's going I know a different guy than
that and it's it was just super
complicated and so even there so watch
this he'll get upset with me about
talking about because I won't frame
advance should be able to respect that
and I and I and I told him I said man
it's hard it's a hard thing to talk
about and your people have to talk about
I don't say men don't anybody to be like
forever like I don't subscribe to that
yeah and so they're there it is yeah
yeah but uh
my wife so [ __ ] much you have no idea
yeah I mean oh I wouldn't write when it
happened I went back I took my wife I
walked already out I took my wife into
the bathroom with my cousin Andrew and I
said I'm gonna tell you something and I
need you not to have emotion about it
she was like that's not fair I go
mmm-hmm
no you need to just shut it down and she
said okay I said re slip me Molly this
woman I haven't seen her mad like that
ever and but what really sucked is no
one took care of me in that moment like
I was like I'm the one that's [ __ ]
scared and she was so she went okay what
do you need for me some money to get out
of the house I think I'm going not gonna
say goodbye to the girls I need to get
the [ __ ] out here I'm gonna go to the
store and I'm gonna wait for my flight
there and I'm gonna go drink she went
okay I said I need you to get me packed
she was like deal packed me got me in a
car service gave me a kiss and my packed
it means like a toothbrush backpack in
blood pressure medicine I weighed the
store the first person I saw was David
Spade Oh David Spade it's like how you
doing I said I've been molly'd and he
was like huh and then already walked in
the same room and he's like are some
tamale stop being a [ __ ] about it and
I'm like it was so [ __ ] it was such a
fucked-up night everything about it like
I'm on the plane just blowing up going
like walking up and down the aisle like
hey anyone wanna party you know it's
just is it was insane was [ __ ] Molly's
be pure
the ecstasy we used to get was just
basically amphetamines and I think
that's basically but Molly man the new
model isn't that bad to start feeling
good immediately
panic set in when he when he said to me
he goes I said are you on something he
was acting weird he was I don't know are
you on something I went no and he was
pretty sure and I went yeah I'm sure Ari
and he goes okay I'm gonna tell you
something and you cannot be mad about it
I know
all right he goes you're on Molly and I
went what he was I slipped you Molly
and subdue Molly so it's already
happened I go did you talk to my
cardiologist about this he was like
excuse me I said I'm on blood-pressure
medicine already did I mean this might
kill me anyone I didn't think about that
let go I go whoa hold on I gotta get a
real plane tonight he's like mom I
didn't realize that either okay but it's
already happened and I was [ __ ] I had
a panic attack so I was like I was like
oh my god I am feeling this like this is
what I've been feeling and I thought I
was just having like little flighty
anxieties and I was like oh [ __ ] I'm on
Molly and then I started freaking out my
cousin Andrew randomly walked up I love
my cousin Andrew sat next to me and I
started rubbing his back and I felt a
lot better and then Joey Diaz came over
and once Joey Diaz got there I was like
I was like goddamn he's so beautiful
like the Sun was backlit and I could see
the the leaves and I saw Artie's eyes
are really pretty and I was like holy
[ __ ] I was like this is [ __ ] awesome
but I also in the moment was like I was
well aware of the repercussions of this
I was like you are my friend and now you
have [ __ ] up us being friends forever
because my wife will not let you but my
house I will never be able to defend
going on vacation with you again
my wife will there's certain things
where my wife side why would you do that
my daughters are now gonna hate you
the worst part is like a month later my
daughter's come we're all sit at the
table we were talking about it and my
daughter I love walks by my wife said
hey let's drop it got ears in the room
and Isla goes no I know what happened
and we're like what Georgia an island
came in we have friends she said yeah
kids at school talked about it I said
what'd she just say the kids at school
know what told me what happened I said
what'd they tell you and they go what
happened that re roofied you and raped
you I was like what she was like yeah
yeah he raped you right I was like no
eaters like no sometimes dad when you've
been roofied you don't know you've been
raped no one [ __ ] rapes my backyard
like what [ __ ] what
cool kisses I got raped and they don't
even bring it up then I goes he didn't
rape me you know like why didn't he rape
you I was like why would he raped me and
I'm like well why would he drug you he's
not gonna rape you I'm like no one raped
what was greater than 10th grade and 8th
grade now but yeah but it was it was
just such a [ __ ] up sanera but then
that's the way partisan you know you
live this life I don't the public like
this just gonna come back you know it's
like what the [ __ ] do Somali the best
part of this joke the best part of the
story
my wife's still [ __ ] livid still
[ __ ] livid my daughters go home I
only did Ari give you then I go he gave
me half Molly and our friends are at the
table
why would someone give you a half a
Molly and Liam leans forward and in the
fried by the way I haven't laughed about
this event yet I had not won I haven't
found any part of this funny I haven't
laughed about the entire incident yet
Lee Anne leans forward in a perfect
teaching moment she goes he gave him
half a Molly because he's Jewish huge
thanks to her for that and to everybody
who is still on this ride with us please
shoot me a tweet and let me know that
you actually like stuck with it that
whole time if you have any notes any
ideas how I can improve
I really am serious about wanting this
to get better and better and your
feedback is gonna be very very welcome
that was the last one we taped before
the shutdown
and I don't even know where or how we're
moving forward from here
but we're gonna I know it it's gonna be
a wild ride
so thank you for [ __ ] being here man
yeah dude sweet